what's up fool
what's up fool podcast what's up fool
parking with Felipe Esparza
Rodrigo Torres yeah man at least Esparza
and our super special guest Joey cocoa
Diaz what's up fool what's up baby right
here man under the [ __ ] canopy hey
[ __ ] Burbank ready to go we got light
e4g go for his night shining today down
the block from the Italian restaurant I
got no customers oh my god you know they
had one customer that we had your seat
arm as a guest and he cut off the bus
right there but a sandwich and a Dover
how was it he said it was all right he
said was good it looked pretty oily yes
oh he's good we're talking about that
last week oily on the sandwich what type
of sandwich oh they tied a meatball okay
it's gotta have a little grease to it
dry huh super like those subway
meatballs those [ __ ] things they dry
it and [ __ ] that that desert
meatballs I just know from looking at me
you're gonna [ __ ] die I've had the
all that frozen [ __ ] I've had the the
favorite imitation crab with no children
gold you know that way pescetarian yeah
but it was all right it was the best
crab sucks imitation crab is just fish
it's white fish that's made into that
they spray paint purple yes real fish
huh looks plastic tastes so bad what
some food how's your Netflix special
going who the [ __ ] knows they're
generous with that call Netflix every
day and a stabs things didn't even give
you tabs now they're starting to release
numbers on you know how many watch bird
box how many watch Troma but they were
pretty quiet up for years you know it's
no weird how you don't
I've been here 20 years I'll [ __ ] what's
the difference what's it you know you
you work hard you do it and you pull it
out and it's me Madhu we're just talking
about the outside like some expectations
people expect all this [ __ ] you just
could do the best you could do you know
once you start getting two numbers and
you had you had those people I tell you
Bryce or so many tickets I even sell a
lot of booze when I do too you know like
those people number those Peter oh gosh
I don't read I got the package for
alcohol I didn't worry about that [ __ ]
all I'm trying to do is go up there and
do the best 15 minutes I got and let's
get off the stage I don't want to sell
t-shirts I don't under nothing I'll take
some pictures I talked to him
but all that [ __ ] just throws my game
off so if you start thinking about like
oh goodbye I love people I'm gonna start
a podcast cuz I'm gonna be the next Joe
Rogan I'm gonna make a ton of money in
your podcast fails because you think any
I'm gonna be the next hour sturdy you
have the wrong motivations just sitting
someone to do a podcast for a year but
we all think a plan B yeah how many
numbers in my dorm what number did you
get up - I don't know what number my
podcast is if you think I have time to
check iTunes every day you're out of
your [ __ ] mind you do the best work
you can you put it out there and you let
it fall into God's hands after that
there's nothing you could do you were
gonna an audition to December 18th and
you gotta wait for two [ __ ] weeks
over the holidays to see if you got that
I went through five to six of those big
movies and [ __ ] - they make you wait and
they tell you no and you're like I wait
and then the movie sucks and you're like
what what was the difference it wasn't
meant to be so once I walk on the
audition now it's over like I don't know
what you're talking about I don't give a
[ __ ]
sometimes they cause and comes they call
you three weeks later it's - we have too
much on our plate to worry about I
learned I want to hit on it when I hear
that people write about a certain
comedian and there's another comedian
saying because he don't know numbers
either but somebody just decide to write
and were the highest rated show on
Comedy Central
who said who told you Comedy Central
charge
this ain't [ __ ] to blow smoke up your
ass they tell you all the same [ __ ]
it's like very calling all of his
clients undeniable what's up as you go
chillin bro right here live do you like
a fly on the wall what's crackin doin
over there bro Murph you know what baby
Ricky Steamboat uh-huh your perfume nah
just fraser-smith there's no I I can't
smell like perfume it's like Febreze
perfume or something the rest of the
country's freezin right now oh my god
bro we beat death yeah we got turquoise
20 of you guys - Lisa what made you
decide to leave Blue's Clues right here
what oh man Lisa at the club said to you
first the owner said man it's a man at
first he was like optimistic yeah man
you know man we're a snow city we're
gonna take care of the snow but then by
Saturday night instead it's a Mary Ellen
Friday night Friday night he said if you
want to leave I won't take it personal
it's gonna be a good one my wife went to
the supermarket she said everything was
gone all the shelves were empty but then
I started looking for backup flights and
I booked him on a couple backup flights
and they got cancelled right away out of
there
so we had to cancel Saturday's shows
because the only the latest flights out
were 6:00 p.m. so he's not gonna be able
to do any shows and leave Saturday night
so we gotta have him leave Sunday
Saturday morning and I'm glad they did
because like starting a like noon 1:00
o'clock come down I was in New York on
Thursday I was supposed to shoot a show
Friday and leave Saturday morning and
you know me dog
and my mind I wasn't gonna LAX to March
7 I take play I take breaks from their
lands so I'll do a whole four or five
weeks out of Burbank and two local
that's the main thing is given LAX a
[ __ ] breather sometimes and I got
this call to do this [ __ ] show on
Vice land so they said you come back to
New York you shoot I plan on staying
there for a weekend I said let me do the
show and then I just stay stay Friday
Saturday and Sunday and I looked at the
dates and I'm like I grew up there only
[ __ ] [ __ ] at this time like only a
[ __ ] idiot this time of year next
time before you go back these just call
me no we weren't going to accept it and
it was the only date they were giving us
well yeah just say no just say no we
can't do we don't do January and nowhere
like that no we're like we're a
Bridgeport the week before Bridgeport a
week before I don't mind though the
first two weeks okay
see it's the first two weeks that okay
the last two weeks of January and all of
February's colors just a voice just a
voice just a boy there's no reason to go
there because the East Coast is a
different mentality number one it dies
after the first but it doesn't pick up
till Valentine's Day the East Coast in
California have different mentalities
that's number one even in those times is
just a lot to do but there's not it's
cold so yeah if you want to make good
money
Buffalo one of those places are good
like just second we get January
the thought third and fourth week of
January you don't want to be in the East
Coast why I tell you why when I was a
kid there was a park called Hudson
County Parker there was an island in the
middle in the summertime you were able
to paddle boat and there was an island
in the middle of one that's the third
week of January since I was a kid it was
called the island of insanity party and
they would wait for that river to freeze
and they would push kegs over think
about that pushing kegs over this river
and we go into the middle of the island
with the quaaludes and we drink it would
be called the island of insanity party
whatever time you stayed there you stay
that too so when I got the call to go do
that show I was like [ __ ] the Farmers
Almanac I don't look at that [ __ ] and I
don't look at the [ __ ] well yeah that
tells you what its gonna be like the
next year and I don't look at the
weather I don't believe the weather is a
hypothesis it's just an educated guess
probably weather is anybody could be a
[ __ ] weatherman look at the weather
in California on Monday and I'll tell
you what the weather in New York is
gonna be on Saturday it's the same [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] it just goes across the
country and sometimes we get knocked out
by winning [ __ ] but one day 24 hours
[ __ ] yeah but it doesn't matter it's
still the second coldest we you know I
heard Monday it was so [ __ ] cold in
the East Coast yeah I was so [ __ ]
cold so I shot right away I talked to
the agents and they're like well we can
buck here we got a week for you you go
right from the show on Vice land to the
weekend and I think you know what I'm
gonna stick to my [ __ ] guns I
know better
don't [ __ ] with these people back home
this time of the year I got I got in a -
I made reservations was already gonna
Peter Luga steakhouse nice [ __ ] steak
that seems a [ __ ] oh my god they
chopped up nice for you we went over
there like gentlemen
yeah cuz that's why I was staying right
in Williamsburg so it was only seven
minutes away from the hotel so we went
over there 3:45 I don't need meat after
6:00 it and I am too old man oh yeah you
got to eat meat before 6:00 my old man
and I [ __ ] we split the steak
whispers all her fries and we split the
salad I smoked a number they got me a
balcony I smoked the number on the Bob
and I stayed in watching articles Mexico
next morning my call time was at 10:00
absolutely living like a doctor I got a
bidet and I had some eggs you know what
time I got back to my room 12:45 so I
had plenty of weed for the weekend to
hold me oh I know you know what I'll
send my room I'll watch some movies oh
it's I don't want to take a chance
I called JetBlue I had a mid take it so
I called JetBlue and before I said
anything
JetBlue was answering the phone hi
waving rebook fries because of the
snowstorm I love online I said you got a
mid ticket in an aisle they said yeah at
7:44 I said book pop on that
[ __ ] I got out to get the car
pick me up if ya Friday I had to cop
pick me up at 4 [ __ ] Kennedy Airport
all that TSA and all that did you scare
on white people I had had the Express
ticket I was the first one in line
they're just scared white people that's
all that's all ABC does World News
Tonight they just get white people TSA
is intact everybody was there hell yeah
I was um I walked right through TSA I
don't know I'm gonna have to kill I went
into the palms
you know me goes like a gentleman I had
a house [ __ ] sirloin the mashed
potatoes was about seven o'clock it was
five o'clock five o'clock when you in
New York you late the steaks a little
steak bombs Kennedy I walked upstairs at
[ __ ] 7:00 I was the first one on the
plane and I was back in [ __ ] LAX at
10:40 it was 40 minutes early and it was
20 minutes late leaving that's just to
tell you it's all [ __ ] they attack
on our own just to scare white people I
was on the 405 by [ __ ] 11 o'clock
like a doctor [ __ ] you
after November 10th I do not go to the
East Coast and I don't go back to either
the second week of January or sometime
in March I avoid it like the place it's
good money well you got a good chance
again stuck on an apple for nine or ten
hours and again I come prepared
I got xanax in the bag I got a vapor pen
I got an iPhone I got the [ __ ]
charger I got the iPad the stars of
death I got this dog no more stars no
more stars you know rid of a bra yeah
they got they one other business they
fall on their own if they fell but they
got some new [ __ ] out now see
my assistant my my niece is 22 but she
got a 40 year old boyfriend who's a
chemist and he's been coming out here to
do interviews and he was telling me that
that what they're about to do with
reefer is phenomenal
like the liquids the vapors the edible
so he had a some guy turn me on so he's
no edibles 98 percent THC made with
oxygen they blend it it comes in a
capsule when I woke up this morning know
where I was
you took it last night I took three of
them before my daughter's more we take
class I was [ __ ] up I don't know what
time I went to bed I don't know none all
I know is I woke up this morning and had
to go back to bed I was the girls never
back to bed I felt her kissing me before
school she gave me a kiss now when I
think gave another kiss and I miss
kickboxing and everything I was stoned
this morning charge my phone oh man we
were out there and now I was garlic I
didn't think about if I was gone fools
when I got on my plane they upgraded me
the first class well yeah so I was you
know passing out and then they move in
the first class my pastime right away
immediately ate like three edibles
passed out but when we were affrighted
to Detroit I got scared because I was
all white and hood at the beginning of
that movie Fargo I'm looking about white
in the air and water on the floor and I
said oh [ __ ]
they're okay Oh the pilot was safe we
couldn't fly no more so we waited inside
a tournament for another new pilot a
good one she came here bro they would
dance the everybody your last name oh
you connector from Detroit to Rochester
no for real from Rochester to Detroit to
LA okay yes he's connected to yeah
Detroit but I've made it home too
you were supposed to connect in Chicago
they canceled all the Chicago cuz they
were having the same problem I can't
sleep and I can't stop the planes and
then but then they when that's why I had
to put you guys on separate flights
because I would Lana
there was one seat left on the flight I
got you on and then no more it was sold
out immediately and then I had him go
down to Atlanta because there was a
similar departure time but anything
after nine o'clock goes afraid you guys
are getting stuck in Roger hello he fled
from a ladder to alley about four hours
yeah first class yeah really yeah I got
I got first class on that [ __ ] you
passed I passed [ __ ] tired I didn't
sleep the night before you guys flew in
doesn't have bought in Roger yeah a
little I think Jeb blue goes there -
yeah JetBlue and spirit you don't want
to get on spirit they let you fly that
plane to get there early you had some
mistake I got a plan man when I go on
the road no trouble I don't want no
drama so many thing that people are
saying that audio volume is low so I
just [ __ ] make it as easy as possible
for myself no spirit I avoid Chicago no
frontier before I [ __ ] I agree to the
date I looked to see make sure there's a
plane ticket back early so there's no
misunderstanding on son bag get back by
11:00 attend the Lord's Day
I got [ __ ] parameters book I'll stay
at home I don't give a [ __ ] yeah the
older you get the more you gotta put
your foot down and say no I knew in 1998
I was never working Sundays
like I started in 98 telling people
Sundays and not happening you know many
times I left Rogan on the road on a
Sunday ask ask I don't want something I
would tell him someday you're gonna have
kids and soon enough he stopped working
Sunday I have a dog little filly working
Sunday snow you gotta eat dinner with
your wife on Sunday even if you don't
have a family you gotta have a family
you know I like I used to hate waking up
on a hotel room on a Sunday morning and
they're being football on and me [ __ ]
waiting for a seven o'clock show to open
up to some [ __ ] jackoff stuff like
Tobey Hicks you know I just don't like
it I just never liked it
I remember in 2009 that was in a quick
comedy before the podcast boom started I
got a call from the funny bones and they
off him like seven weeks of work there
was [ __ ] money and I go and they were
like Wednesday through Sunday and I go
knock that down cuz I'm not working
Sundays and they said well then you
can't work he and I should find they
hung up the phone they called back an
hour later and they said we'll cut
something out with you to work Sundays
and I was like Hello Wednesday's either
like I knew back then already what my
parameters were what I wanted to do what
you know won't come when Philippe and I
started touring it was Tuesday through
Sunday yeah though passable by Friday
you want to put a gun in your [ __ ]
mouth I'm a Saturday and The Improv you
should do three shows on Saturday you
know so by Saturday 10 o'clock you want
in your [ __ ] you don't want to hear your
jokes you don't want to hear a joke
then you gotta stay there all [ __ ] day
on Sunday and do [ __ ] Sunday at 7:00
for a bunch of who goes for showing us
something that I don't want to talk to
those people in real life
denim saying who those who is show on
Sunday night so I don't I don't want no
part of it Thursday night's my night
when I was snorting coke Thursday night
from professionals go up Thursday nights
and Sunday night so Sunday night you're
in a comedy club you're a [ __ ] Punk
you should be out eating somebody's ass
after church and getting through it
right from church right to the [ __ ]
bar that's how we did it in the old days
so Sunday's I don't want to see the
comic
but Thursday's a great night for comely
Thursday I'll meet the main dope you
yeah I love Thursday night they would
show up on Thursday Thursday Friday
Saturday that's Comrie Wednesday stay
humble watch [ __ ] backs military pre
night
yeah I'm on the move for Wednesday's
either you know but I knew this 90 if I
didn't want to work Sunday's and when I
stopped I just said I'm done working
Sunday's and people used to get pissed
at me I don't give a [ __ ] if it is a
holiday on Monday that I work local like
I did this week I did three shows
something at the Comedy Store I did the
two main little shows and whatever
stupid seven o'clock [ __ ] show
stupid seven o'clock show a stupid seven
o'clock show I want to sit across and
this is one I was just dating her we
weren't even married I decided I'm like
she deserves better
Sunday nights we have dinner at 6:00
like a [ __ ] family unit the cats sit
next to us and we throw shrimp that's it
I don't have a [ __ ] what you got to
offer what your offer is it really
doesn't matter to me I want peace of
mind it's the first place I would see
the same night I take if I could leave
the same night out I would there's no
more one o'clock flights and most
airports closer one and you have to be
an hour get stuck in Vegas they give it
to a college in Vegas at 7:00 and get
off the stage of it you can't find it's
the last nights at 9:45 you get stuck in
Vegas - you can't leave Vegas - can't
leave none of these places no more like
the old days but an eight o'clock show
if I get out of that 9:30
take a few pictures in the flames and
midnight I'll get the [ __ ] out of it I
get the [ __ ] out the first flight up
first fly that I'm on
once you hand me that check all bets are
off
I don't want talking Armani I don't even
know what you're talking about
you keep talking you're just talking to
a war I don't know what you don't just
all I'm thinking about is going home to
my daughter
I don't know what you I love the people
yeah next time you come keep talking I'm
not even I don't even give a [ __ ] all
I'm thinking about is going honking my
daughter I don't know what you talking
about I'm a barbecue yeah I have no idea
next time you can yeah sure oh yes in
the debt you know me I'll tell you
whatever you want to hear yeah sure
right yeah oh yeah I want this chitter
chatter you know my face when I try why
don't do podcasts people can live it at
me don't do podcast on the road sorry
Charlie I don't know what kind of
podcast bear trap bro yeah I don't know
what you're getting yourself into
I walked into a room in the owner took
our vanity nothing down in my soda
comedy club podcast either most of the
ones I stay away from the most like
ambush boxing is the essence bro the
funny thing is as soon as I get the
thing that's his radio and like what pod
care like oh you're doing a local
podcast I call the guy out there's a hot
[ __ ] accountant then they call back
and they'll go whoa they want you to the
podcast I said well tell me tell them to
find me a week when I don't have to do
the podcast
and there's silence about it how about
this show show that people are getting
it at least Ali we want to interview him
at this show
Wow sure no you can't promote no capital
bull show is not yeah I'm about to deny
a photo press request because they want
to do a review and then put photos when
I go into a town I go to do stand-up
that's it
I did my comedy podcast in Los Angeles
too much time you know it's always a by
the way by the way we have a comedy
class by the way because that's the
problem there's a by the way if somebody
calls me and says let's do a podcast
it's two minutes in the studio you gonna
walk there and we're gonna do it at
whatever time I might consider it
depending on how I'm feeling but once I
got in to get into a stranger's car
you're done because you don't know it
could be 40 minutes one way forty
minutes the other the guy's late then
they want to stop by your uncle's house
because the fan who Rogan podcast and
wants to take a picture my friends dojo
they are kids they don't want to do
nothing
I want a small Patton watching our
compete oh man that's it that's it
that's it no no I got kidnapped one time
into the last time I were the owner of
the the common the underground comedy
club in Reno Reno oh my god wait yeah is
he still open he's too open there's a
club still open yes great guy great guy
but the radio is too much of a where
yeah they I call after radio he took me
he took me to go buy all the alcohol
with him at for the club
Hertz
and then she convinced me to go I'll
pass out tickets at the mall and let's
say that I can't go into the Walkman or
fall asleep that's where the kids are oh
my god and they would make us go to mall
I always say no oh we get so Jose we
will get there or let the the the night
before real late and then they want to
go to a club no [ __ ] no promotions
never [ __ ] work we got Joe Diaz right
here and then I stopped singing really
only was an address in club attire we
don't know whether the mug the place
[Laughter]
snort coke and get my dick sucked and
you want to interrupt my [ __ ] verbage
[ __ ] on stage and let me get the [ __ ]
yeah we don't do malls we don't do the
bro one time the guy from San Jose
called me send me a plain thing so I get
up there he picks me up some Spanish kid
he picks me up and we actually have to
goes we gotta go to the mall first and
pick up my girlfriend now that's that's
that's rule number one
now you really want to piss me off make
me walk like one time at Boston I got
that some of the more than they will the
elevators broken flights of steps and I
say 60 steps to 7:00 in the morning
though I'm over 50 I'm in the heart
attack zone well I'm not supposed to get
anxiety so you better call
and how am i walking upstairs oh my god
[ __ ] you the [ __ ] power went out they
want to do kinda like radio people have
no idea that we're done like it's been
20 years in LA we've heard every story
everyone's every promoter every me how
action
those were passing after a show let me
holler at you you know it went from 800
to 650 what about the promoter that
[ __ ] me knocked on my door 4:00 in
the morning the cops are looking for him
cuz he ran it on the radio
the radio station knocked on my door
4:00 in the morning to [ __ ] tell me
what about that club in Iowa they all
snort coke the Mexican restaurants a
capital speech they give it a do that
gig but never did it yeah they went to
jail that shut down you go yup from his
formal living room one day goes flipping
through the sky always please he pays
cash he's a big fire I'm ready with him
Chuck you put him on the phone he
[ __ ] pays you at the airport but what
he didn't tell me was that he owned the
Mexican Coke bar in the old town I mean
that's where was he was like being in
the 80s the studio 54
now we're brenton dropped you off no he
did their dad gig and they went to
Whitey's yeah cause Whitey's busy he
dropped me off at a pool no that was a
[Laughter]
penguin oh Jesus Christ
yeah all right ain't no Thursday at 1:00
Penguins Friday at the other photobooth
a quote unquote [ __ ] where they do
gambling
a little comedy club there Wednesday
night is the [ __ ] bowling alley but
this was a different gig this is a
Saturday night gate but you only have
two flights to go with that only two
flights like to when the epidural and
something else
so that's Saturday I left will fly soon
as I get in the truck
I puts the money in my hand and he goes
to me I have another thing for you by
the time we get to the club and I go
what other thing he goes I got you a
little present I go listen I'm gonna do
that no I just smoke pot that's all I'm
sorry it's just some pile and I brush
them don't worry about I go to the room
I smoke some pot I take a shower I eat
some food he picks me up like he says he
is okay the clock was good and that
place is packed the parents are there
the [ __ ] food was off the chain oh
great comedy show boom it ends
once the parents leave you should have
seen what happened at this place it went
from a [ __ ] nice family restaurant it
looks like it does to a dog man he was
coked up and then we did the second show
there was 11 people in the audience but
there was 90 people in the joint all of
them was standing by the bathroom
talking with little cups of booze they
were all gone in the bathroom the do
bumps the show finishes the promoter is
[ __ ] I look at him and I go no you're
not any good I'm gonna be fine
he's [ __ ] it he's [ __ ] joy shits
coming out of his nose I go broke take
me back to the [ __ ] hotel room I go
listen you gotta pick me up at 5:00 if
there's only one flight out of here oh
that connects in Chicago and then from
Chicago you have to connect if you don't
get me on that flight at 6:00 I gotta
wait till 8:00 o'clock at night I'll
[ __ ] kill you
he promised me left and right I'll be
here I'll be here I'll be at five
o'clock
ain't there 515 ain't that I called his
mother's house
I woke the father up I woke bad little
[ __ ]
they found him this kid came to pick me
out of his mind and it stick to the
crank capital over the country it's the
capital crack like when you see people
from with that display from that County
people ask you do you have meth that's
how popular it is from that so I think
after the coke they start doing the math
well that didn't knock that guy didn't a
hundred all the way the airport I didn't
say goodbye to him I just jumped out of
it I big I barely [ __ ] mater
I barely made it he hits me up what CA
what are you coming back go [ __ ]
yourself yeah put me through that
[ __ ] nightmare dawg I was it was like
I was a kid how did this get here you
threw somebody through one of these
[ __ ] Latin comics he was doing like a
flattened comic series once a month he
just called out of the blue you know
what have been packed that first show
the first show was packed and the second
show was packed Felipa but the second
show was back here the cocaine yeah
we're just waiting outside the bathroom
I did one of those gigs but with a
promoter and man I did it in Garden City
Kansas I got picked up a link in a brat
Lincoln cans in a little a small town
and everyone I was going to the show
over there I got paid me cash
both shows were packed but the second
show I was go party was there they went
to a bar the other bidder like $4 like
real cheap they got to went to his house
man was crazy like I was partying with
him next to his crib baby's crib killed
my high five me home it's crazy it's
crazy very like I showed you where to
the Ruben relax instead of waking up all
tired yeah I mean those people are
probably waiting for that day all year
because they have nothing else going on
in that
so they're so excited the promoter can't
wait till you come in and all that then
he's gonna do it up and it's crazy and
it's to the nth degree and you just
you're this there to do a show it's
gonna be an animal has to be party like
that I would anybody party that like
that that never was crazy we all did it
we all did it no big deal we all party
like that at that level if I remember
like when I when I ran into of April
Macie and she told me to a Felipe you
know that Club order the wild wild west
so which one the one over there no Desa
yeah he goes she started laughing like
you outward to jail yeah I would have
been a federal prison even though host
what's his name
the magician Roman John Roman John Roman
went to prison to prison for a year
because I older the owner put the bar in
his name was the world wall West you
don't have comedy clue the guy paid you
cash even though of seven people in the
audience
no I never got to that [ __ ] I worked in
John Roman one time what John Roman had
me at one bar where the guy was a biker
that's what I meant yeah the biker the
girl what about big bullseye gasps yes
yes I get she went to prison first for
embezzle at her job damn yap of her job
so she was gone array she was not there
no more but then her husband there he
with a biker and so it's not Roman but
they all went to prison after her and
then was John Roman now yeah he's out
had to do a year maybe two yeah put that
big for the big plan Alex you were 225
years
what about the big fat guy right over
the owner I don't know the owner I think
was that blond guy looks kinda like a
troll doll his hair was all crazy right
no no no that was another guy you know
the owner was a guy a real fat Mexican
do cuz I remember the first time I did
the gig he goes ape Felipe we're gonna
go to it you watch we're gonna go to the
fights you want to come I say now
it's gonna be fun we're gonna eat after
I mean I'm in the car but what kind of
prizes these little dog fights
it was now I'm good I got out of the car
but if I walking back to my hotel room
and there was the other one in Midland
that's the one Athene no that's the one
little daesil with John Roman then there
was another guy that was a magician oh
that does Jenkins yes
yeah he's won a sex man yeah he was one
what Houston because he was married in
two different states Wow look at me
bigamy he was my water for polygamy so
the first time I did it the first time I
did middlin was a Holiday Inn and they
did Latin calmly and it was me and
Maryland and Paul had done it so he
referred Maryland and that's when the
guy tried to break in the Maryland
Martinez is what a [ __ ] mistake that
would have been Maryland's [ __ ] in the
middle and I even Harvey Weinstein would
eat him so I'm my room and I had
boom-boom-boom-boom with smile and
[ __ ] yelling some guys breaking into
my room help me so I went over there and
we locked the door and that was the end
of that and then I went back a second
time as a headliner and when I walked in
he handed an eight ball on my head he
put coke it was me and somebody else was
featuring and he was the house MC so
what was what was the fat kid from
Houston the one that helped you out
oh yeah that's uh that's all good then
he was being tracked so yeah I was
bought both eight balls both of us an
eight ball for the first show that full
star boy he were anywhere no sock it was
a booze with no socks listen to me
I put the 8-ball in my pocket I did the
first show did the second show I got no
reason to lie to nobody I was a junkie
at the time do you know that he had an
eight ball too and at the end of the
second show he asked me if I had
anything left he had done the eight ball
that he got during the first and the
second show you should have seen the
shape of him on stage
during the second show showing jog going
sweating and when he came off I remember
just looking at him like I'm like I
gotta get off this [ __ ] because that's
me but I'm a man walking over to me
going do you have anything left
yeah I thought I had then the following
week they were on staying the DEA raided
the joint while they were on stage the
DEA raided the joint twice while the
club was going on so there's like a
comic on stage like da that's crazy that
place was they have a Mexicans with the
belt buckles yeah bro so that's why I
didn't know because if somebody yeah
dark to hug our homes
bro that's all that would they didn't
speak the language and then there was
another one in Corpus Christi
that was a casona shop and I'm like I
have them what's that hamburger joint
that's 15 over 50 years old what a
burger no the other one they have it up
and since you're up and up in the
universal when you will stake and share
whatever because it looks like they're
going they have like milk caps raucous
Johnny Rockets it's a was it was a
comedy club that was an old Johnny Oh
that of course is free from the shitty
of the hotel room ever and that's the
place yeah that place definitely still
there but it's caught something now that
they did comedy comedy we called water
so Corpus Christi the county the cross
and I'm I want that burger stand and man
call me
did you get your coke she's kind of
package to co-create [ __ ] amazing
come over here and take mine and I went
over to Marilyn's room and open the
person was just a chunk of yellow I put
it in my pocket I ran back to the club
and I know were you looking for me cuz
yeah got some for you and you gave me a
chunk those are [ __ ] crazy what's up
what's up I don't have a plane in Corpus
remember they have like a plane both no
a plane have lights on it and Corpus
Christi we were in that hotel one time
me and Freddy Soto get a barn there was
a barn in Corpus Christi dogs have him
again you know like when you're in the
car mr. Ewing I'm on my way up my way up
I did be improv lateen all night I did
the Laugh Factory Joaquin oh man I'm on
my way no business at its finest and
mark Babbitt calls you you opening up
for Freddy in Corpus I go perfect my bad
baby was a [ __ ] barn in coop is
Christy like they show they had to push
those the straw to the side but hey also
that one I'll throw that gig there was
no some man huh it was all it was all
grass dirt road and the parking lot was
all dirt right oh it was crazy ideas I
know Joe Medina
they have dancing and they were like a
Corral they were going on a circle huh
dog this is craziness
a circle we detect first of all thank
God for Texas this if it wasn't for
Texas I wouldn't have a common career
there's nobody else booked me like Texas
you could say whatever you want in taxes
or a whole year in text no froggy
violins no more there's no club and
loveth no more all those places is shut
down there was a time when you had
froggy froggy bottoms a chick had the
biggest tits you ever saw in you like
the daughter her name was Julia okay
the biggest taste and it was a
family-run comedy club for years it was
run by like real people
and then one day they didn't want to do
it no they just said we don't want to do
it so I sold it to a Mexican family who
turned the front into a Mexican
restaurant delicious Julia was no beauty
queen winner but she had the biggest
hits in the world didn't suck overall
the shot that comes out they didn't get
any more than 20 people they would tell
you that
no more than 20 people this is what I'm
gonna pay you I took the week with fav
Minh and that was on the funniest Rhys
in my life because it was Regulus and
everybody whatever you wanted a beer in
there you didn't raise you know when you
go to a comedy club weight just comes up
to you now during his show he would just
yell the customers would just yell oh
yeah doing your show I get this matter
what joke you would who never got and
who you will come out with a big fat
tits jumping and she'd take your drink
order or nachos or [ __ ] beginning
cheese burrito but they would just yell
Hulya drive till this day sometimes I
see Fame they go holy and we both just
giggle because it was a whole weekend
there was four shows of everybody going
who Leah who she was the only waste that
a mother in the kitchen and her father
helped her and cash the register in the
sack people then that kid opening up a
comedy club next a lot McKinney od'd in
Seattle who we were just talking about
him somebody asked me if I had to work
that room Kelly Moran had a room next to
Lubbock there was a ton of rooms yeah
tons of rooms in Texas Houston had
spellbinding is the last stop in the
last spot and the staining the Martinez
is one time you know the Spellbinders at
the club where Ralphie may fell through
the stage he was 600 pounds and he fell
through the stage and he sued the club
so the club was still open
after Ralphie suited for about half the
Ralphie moved out lay the club was still
open and whenever Ralphie would say
something to break my balls I wouldn't
say that my great man have we spoken
from the lady from Spellbinders lately
she go [ __ ] you cuz he ended up sooner
so if you call Spellbinders do not use
Ralphie's my name as a reference so I
would tell him if you [ __ ] keep
breaking my balls I'm gonna call that
lady and usually as a reference he fell
through the [ __ ] stage he came out of
the thing that's all folks
how we damn Big Ben
they went under he got up there it was a
chimney bro
I like the 18th minute it just broke and
he went right down like a bag of [ __ ]
nails [ __ ] tremendous hope never that
good you steady with a manager or owner
had the worst weed in the whole wide
world bro and his brother with a DJ he's
the one I took on who that video game
remember it was all Reggie or what they
call it over there Reggie right yeah
stress Mexican weed he always had powers
it was a skinny kid that was the manager
at the yeah laughs stop laughs stop
Mexican kid sweetheart of a kid oh they
were the older they're mark Babbitt mark
Babbitt and then they had the Mexican
kid that was his cousin that used to be
the DJ yeah he quit and he sold coke and
reefer so when you came to town the
guy's name was David yeah you called
David and he told David have anything
ready for you and when you walked into
the lap stop he'd have everything ready
for you coke weed whatever you need
everything was that rules that please
you in over their banks a you you let
you eat those dumplings but never got to
go there anti change dumpling Palace
I loved all that in Houston I loved that
good food I read the whole comedy scene
in Texas listen you have my wife I told
my agent all the time which I apologize
you know because I can't do the things I
used to do I would love to just do a
Texas runs for three weeks
badass I'll go do it you know just a
Texas run for business all those great
cities Austin Horvath I'll take you know
just it never ends you could you could
sleep it to a year in tax
[ __ ] you stop by Waco Waco you could
just live downtown
I used to pretty much stay with a girl
in Houston during the week an open mic
there I would say a couple of dollars
and then
I would walk the whole month of July and
Houston and just stay with her that's
the way you almost died
no that was Beaumont cuzzo same girl huh
no cuz you were late you said you told
me manfully premiere for them for the
Zanna who would have died no no the hope
will kept the cope saved your life both
of them yeah the coconut like an idiot
month later try the same thing yeah
Beaumont Texas bro was where I almost
died you know what time you stood there
just to Monday Wednesday Wow I remember
you say lengua missed your [ __ ] I
messed up Sunday I slept all day welcome
Tuesday I was still sick I woke up
Monday I was still sick I woke up
Tuesday I was still sick Wednesday I got
up and I was walking around with my face
was still bent it was like I had got a
stroke the values there was so many of
my blood system I spoke on the phone my
wife's a brat Gary I'm gonna stay two
weeks I'm gonna do a sauce okay sit down
here remember that that Wednesday my
friends that girl's boyfriend picked me
up and he had free passes for the
Intercontinental Hotel his company that
he worked for had an account there they
have like three rooms so I stayed in
there for three days and rehabbed
valiums came out of my system it would
just numbed out all your facial muscles
it was crazy
that was crazy I was crazy all the times
I had to step back and go wow I gotta
stop this the thing that was the
funniest out of all that was that that's
sad they met I ran out of coke and I
called this kid and he goes I don't know
if you want to do business with these
people I just want to do an Eightball
let's go and he took and they took me to
a town that's really racist
it's where the KKK is behind both
Beaumont I think it's called Weiser
I think don't don't quote me on that and
he took me to a KKK place at 4:00 in the
morning like they had the tattoos the
picture of Hitler's on the wall the
whole damn supremacists supremacy I
walked in with him and there were like
eight of those guys and like I'm a boy
what's your name Joey Joey Jim I think I
saw you and I go as I was breaking out
the money they've all hundred dollar
bills so I go how much for the aimpoint
I got 300 I think I goes what's your
last name and I go Diaz and they just
froze like they're like we shouldn't be
doing business with you
well I came the three of ours takes the
aim of the 8-ball I just walked out of
there I was like they gonna kill me they
say a word to me why there's but racism
stops when Ben Franklin shows up what's
Ben Franklin shows up you know what
harmony how a Chinese people what's up
fool this Tuesday you can Joe Diaz at
the Comedy Store around tonight
no next Tuesday next Thursday January
31st you doing it - yeah doing a second
show okay with our boys Spyder stolen
right I think he's putting two on that
night yeah blue at 10:30 whatever don't
and Anthony Jeselnik is on the one
you're on right George George Perez if
you thought release I on the first show
on the first show I'm on the first show
gonna show up with a weed you mean speed
we speed weed that dude's got some good
[Laughter]
he's got the [ __ ] those things [ __ ]
you up I liked his blood right back was
people were backwards but it's the real
tobacco leaves your real cancer where
Sadler in the war stars I thought you
had like a spare pack bag somewhere no
they don't even make him as strong as
strong as those anymore they don't make
him I think he's making them but there's
certain places that sell them yeah it's
on the DL they're not sown he just he
just stopped calling he called one day
and I know what time you want to meet
and he goes from now and I gotta charge
you for the bag and at that time I had
given edible for like four months three
months then I went to Boston I ate a
half somebody threw one up on stage I
took a bite out of it and they weren't
doing anything to me so I just stopped
this week was the first time I did those
I did what with the milligrams on those
capsules there are a hundred apiece I
haven't checked the ones we have some
capsules but they're CBD and THC equal
amount one to one but I don't know the
milligrams I got a look at that yeah I
like because I get higher since I don't
eat the edible I let you do some [ __ ]
stoned
I love getting on alcohol you know at
the end of it all I don't think nothing
except my reefa like I don't want to be
part of sobaco but listen the baby goes
to bed late dirty my wife follows are
about 20
I'm done with her so til 11 o'clock
that's my time sometimes I watch TV but
most the time I just call my office and
I just listen to music and there's
nothing that brings me more satisfaction
than getting high and listen the whole
music sometimes I go to my office office
with a podcast and I got the vinyl and I
just bust our vinyl [ __ ] for two
hours
smoke double this is all directed [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's my way that's the only
reason clean again that's why I wouldn't
give up breathing that is the reason why
it's the last thing that keeps me it's
the only thing I'm doing that's the
illegal I think anxiety pills those
little [ __ ] prescription ones okay I
eat them when I go to the store before I
got on stage that's as illegal as I get
shoplift life is like well you know look
AAA and na they have like oh what 20
percent 25 maybe success rate there's 75
percent failure rate right and there are
so many of you guys who have come off of
harder things and just gone on to just
you just stay steady with weed no
alcohol no nothing and that's enough for
you guys and and I think that there's
something that needs to be researched in
that I think sober because sober and die
a horrible words there are horrible
words that should removed
should be removed from our vocabulary
cuz it already stops you before you want
to start I don't listen I want you to be
happy
let's start right right there
I want Felipa to be happy I want you to
be happy I want the manager to be happy
if the manager diets all day
if she sticks to her way watch the
points all day and at night she has a
half a cup of Breyers ice cream what do
you want me to do look at her and say
stick to your diet walking by well gonna
die in that casket do you think that
piece of bread made a difference in your
death when you put butter on without the
restaurant I'm telling you not to eat
the whole loaf but to eat a piece of
bread and butter they kill you you just
lift an extra weight at the gym or
whatever when I got off cocaine it was
the saddest day of my life because I
thought I wouldn't be funny anymore they
took that there were so many doubts but
I also knew one thing when I was facing
federal prison charges federal prison
charge its federal time they couldn't
get me to stop doing drugs
they couldn't god it would come to I the
24-hour I take a knock on my door pissed
see how many times they came to my house
in two years
I loved it every times they opened the
door zilch
I don't open the door for nobody bring a
warrant [ __ ] even then you're gonna
he'll wake up myself in this
[ __ ] you understand me my point
being is that you can't put parameters
like that on people I want you to give
something up I want you to look at
yourself and go okay I like my burritos
I like my bean and cheese burritos I
love my cupcakes and I love my ice cream
you got to give up two of us just give
up two of those it's called a lifestyle
change I still want you to have
something to be happy if it's one
cigarette a day that's so beard what am
I gonna do what am I gonna do you know
but when I was fighting myself not to do
coke not to do coke but I do cook when
I'd stop and just leave it to God just
leave it
same thing with diets I'm not gonna
bread good luck good luck
good luck I'm only gonna eat that this
and this on the road you think they got
those are the Holiday Inn because they
have that okay you know I'm gonna juice
and I'm gonna love it what happens when
you go on the road on the road well I
should be a spot that's what you want to
do and your [ __ ] road work is
happened to find the nearest juice spot
and Oklahoma what are your [ __ ]
chances I'm saying see you got to be
realistic with your goals I always knew
that I didn't need to do a coke I'm they
do Harold I'm need to pills I'm they do
none the reefer is like a kid having a
teddy bear I love teddy bears we all
like that teddy bear you know I suck to
pacify it so I was six I broke one of my
mother's Chinese dolls and my mother
said you got you got you got two deals
here you gonna give me all the pacifiers
cuz they have like any of them I
wouldn't put where I'm out in person
like I'd be outside fighting Rudy the
Haitian and when things got deep I'd say
hold on for a second I've run to a
little corner my comeback was like a
cigarette yeah it was terrible I would
get to a value of my mother man go I'll
be right back can I go in the closet
suck my pacifier now [ __ ] what we say
give me your savings
I like seven thought I was saved so I
had to give of the five so you ain't
getting my money you have to kill me to
take my seven hundred yeah I would save
money from the bar I was bartending I
was working at the bar is like a like a
bar backslash janitor she would make me
clean the toilets and [ __ ] take the
tampons out of the period box she told
me there was a buried treasure in there
one day they even gave me a map
oh yeah yeah cuz I was like a little [ __ ]
they say that for the heart I used to
make my own maps and make-believe like I
found the quarter like my mother when
mother would have a roll of quarters and
I would open it and take a quarter round
and put it under a beer box
look I found this map and the
bartender's name was pepper but he had
thick glasses so they called them pepper
CA go right for the blind guy cuz he had
thick glasses one day and my mom set me
up I got to the board I come here we
found let me get the map nation gave me
the map and the money was hidden in the
woman's bathroom in a box next to the
woman's bathroom I didn't know what that
box was I didn't know where that was the
period box and this in the seventies and
they didn't have tampons that Kotex
those big thing bricks women put between
their legs was labelled with a belt was
I kind of inch [ __ ] long and they
rolled it up and it was like a [ __ ]
disgusting big pad and I remember going
in there with my pirate hat on his ship
walking the steps and looking at the
batter you guys have seen the [ __ ]
top of them like this tool because my
mother had two bathrooms next to each
other the woman stole some like all I'm
a rich man I'll never forget sticking my
hand and [ __ ] and that thing was
stuck and I pulled that bloody thing out
and it was rolled up like I said like a
[ __ ] like with those cold cotton
rolls yeah with blood marsupial juice
there was it was dog I threw it in there
ran out of there crying and [ __ ] I don't
even watch
Kotex commercials like I'm a come on I
change them I'm still pissed [ __ ] that
so that that that's the thing I don't
like the word die I don't like the word
sober I think you used to fall off the
wagon harder and faster when you were
trying to low carb and stay sober those
were like those there you go I was just
doing but right now I should tell when I
fell off I said no to the what I really
wanted to eat and I say yes to the craic
but I should have just phone an eight
that Sunday I know that a later on I
would have been stronger to say no the
crack but every game we talk I already
told myself no to what I really wanted
and now this one I really wanted to but
I can't deny myself to the courage I
always know what I'm gonna fall out
because at first it starts off with me
wanting a drink oh I never had them
enchilada or I top it or I say let me
smile at him you smell it then the wrong
when I'm alone it's like one beer in the
green room I'm like by itself
nobody knows step but um but that really
because I do I really don't want to
drink you don't like no I really don't
want to drink I really want to do
something cold really really bad but I
know if I if I'm buzzed it's easier for
me to ask somebody
I remember one no you don't like alcohol
I've seen you drink every type of
alcohol and you don't have a specific
drink you just drink to get drunk and
you don't like any of it it just went
funny well now that time when I started
partying hard and I called you for the
Houston Texas a probably somebody and I
was party with the same guy you
mentioned for three nights straight he's
the only guy he was gone he had one
dollar but he was there he was making
food cost it's crazy the people the
journeys that we bumped into on the road
I think of a lot of those people now
there's still a waitress from El Paso I
talked to I still call each other every
90 days she lives in Iowa Kansas and
whenever like comedian goes to what
would you call me and get tickets or
whatever so
well I still talk to her bunny funny
bunnies good way there's a lot of people
over the years that [ __ ] great people
that differently party hard lady a girl
then there's asian girl and her crazy
husband where you know passel o pass it
was one of those places that was scary
that was scary like Wednesday night
Tuesday night was military night and you
go there and you'd go to that bar they
went to and you me everybody had coke
everybody echo you know the scariest
thing that ever happened to me no paso
was going home with a girl on Wednesday
night doing everything having a great
time snored until 6:00 in the morning
and then like gonna take a piss and I'm
coming back that she's changing and
she's there go pick up my kid and take
them to school I'm like what are you
talking about
you could smell coke like this and drink
and go pick up a kid but then the
scariest was Friday night when they came
back to the show
and you don't know what to say you just
shake the guy's hand she's like that's
why I was with though to the earlier
right we have a good time in Ewing I
know right
and the guy's big and muscular and [ __ ]
I'll pass over the original club the one
the one had the little German store
downstairs the one that had the gay guy
that was the manager yeah Sean John that
was he was cool the best clubs ever
that's where they had the Mexican guy
that cleaned the club afterward but he
was also the house MC so you would he
would when you'd walk in bar would say
give give me a long intro the first
night it was like you know did
basketball I did MADtv parts like that's
too short I want you to write a couple
paragraphs the boss his boss so you have
to go he would go up things I enjoy with
the captain school he graduated from
McKinley in 1970 and even he would
really go what the [ __ ] that's how he
busted that guy's balls and I never
forget new years he kept saying please
don't draw confetti up in the air
because me and my wife the vacuum won't
suck it up because they were the
janitors at the club dog I to confetti
on purpose
IQ pounds out of confetti the next thing
is walking around
I had gotten my hands and knees and
picked one up over there for 12 hours
all those clubs have memories that I
tell Lee all the time another comics
that what I'm doing on stage now is the
work we were doing in the 90s like it's
starting to pay now right now I see that
roadwork on stage oh I got this in that
time in Buffalo oh I got this from that
time in Iowa you know no good deed goes
unpunished like all those rooms or a
nightmare to do well we crack jokes
about them but we all got something from
them you know I'm saying at the end we
all want yeah no matter how bad the room
was no matter if you have to sleep in
the [ __ ] kitchen the old Cleveland
club you had to sleep in the kitchen the
guy that would wake you up was the guy
delivering beer in the morning you can
leave - the guy delivered beer like they
would lock you in there at night and you
couldn't leave - I got delivered B and
you went outside and you [ __ ] eyes
like you're like what the [ __ ] I can't
see cuz you've been in the darkness I
got a thousand of those stories you know
we paid our [ __ ] dues you know I mean
that's am I paying you do some time
there's gonna be fuck-ups you know we
have Fred Stoller I'm gonna show he was
tell about yeah I did this room one time
and - son the waitress and half of the
staff was staying agree and are in the
condo and I was that clever suicide man
with what came out Gary hood Oh glass
laughs nah yeah and the woody Barcena
stood there in joy joy Medina woody
burst and I were staying the same comedy
condo with two-way staff and a manager
and they were all watching TV and then a
little by little go to bed like if I was
just stay there now I wouldn't even stay
there
they were happened to you
time those were the worst there's always
that old comic
that was a very diamond I was gonna take
over the world but he's you're there
that week and he's staying there for a
few days he's friends with the owner but
there's always something weird nice
[ __ ] condos that condo [ __ ] was a
life of debt but you do it you don't
even know you do you're just so happy to
be there happy man he's just so happy to
be there as a comic then when you look
back on them you have him in the condo
in Dallas
what was that plumbing Dallas it's still
there hyenas hyenas 15 years ago the
cousin the owner's cousin is Spanish and
he got to talk to Latino life vessel and
to adding that into the vessel it was an
extra hundred bucks as Professor are you
50 [ __ ] dollars
yeah so this guy would pay you $100 for
the show and I went to the condo and I
want to cross the street I'm one of
those those roles for the big pound cake
yeah I bought pound cake for breakfast
and I put it in the kitchen I didn't
open it Lisa at least the next morning I
looked in then there was roaches and
everything there just there were roaches
in the refrigerator that's when it's bad
and you won until the kind and I was the
headliner
but when I walked into the features room
there were two towels as a curtain I
remember going to [ __ ] choke you
Charlie's in Alaska and it's [ __ ]
Alaska in the bedroom had two windows
broken it was the liquor room to the
club which was across the street they
turned them into a condo there was a bad
little stand-up shower and I went up
there with my girlfriend the time I
didn't know
it was just a single [ __ ] bed the
windows were broken breezes blowing in
here the breeze off the [ __ ] Alaskan
water oh who the [ __ ] I was my first
my second row gig first one wasn't Ogden
Utah and the fifth dribble and the first
one was in Rock Springs Wyoming Rock
Springs Wyoming is such a bad town that
the feds had to go in there and take it
over
I'm watching the report on 60 minutes
ago on Rock Springs my homie the Mafia
what are they talking about wait did you
get there well I saw Rock Springs on the
antenna where I go the mob takes the
hookers from Vegas when their [ __ ]
are busted and it flies into Rock
Springs and they have strip clubs there
and they put them like through a farm
leak they stitch up the [ __ ] I sit up
they dice it up a little bit what's
their [ __ ] get busted in Vegas from
like a year long stretch of sucking [ __ ]
in Vegas they go The Rock Springs
Wyoming and they get their life together
they got like many camps and training
camps dogs for like five hours to give
you a lap dance and Rock Springs around
me it's the best lap dance you for that
they had a pizza place in there that was
fed and there was the Mafia it was crazy
it was crazy the feds had to come take
the town back my still remember going
through that town and then telling me I
never met the headliner before I know he
was and then like we only I won't roll
me up the Cheryl I had to share a room
with a [ __ ] man you know how bad I
was like what personnel clipper has
balls that was terrible that was like
the beginning of comedy going I don't
we're here we're here now right 27 years
later was storia banging
what's up fool what's up fool man
January 26 I'm in Turlock California man
that [ __ ] is sold out what Scott Turlock
California
bye-bye celeea California February 1st
fast theater sold-out there's two things
available for Coachella February 2nd
spotlight 29 tickets to available
Birmingham Alabama I'm there February
15th through the 17th at the Stardust in
verse started oh man Hoover Alabama
Raleigh North Carolina February 22nd to
24th at the brand-new 460 seat new
improv we went on turn off this weekend
all right he's all wet
I'll be home laughing Joey COGO Diaz
next Thursday January 1st Jody will be
on the first show at 8:30 with Lisa Ann
and I'll be in the second show as joy it
was George Perez de Chivo and who else
Anthony Jeselnik gentleman Jeselnik so
good temper comedy people yourself a
bunch of stars at the show the good time
I think the comments left by the best
lineups ever as far like you look at me
when I look at the Gotham audience look
the Gotham lineup and I compared to the
company store lineup a comparable matter
but I rather see it the comedy store one
as a comedy fan if I was not a comedian
just to rub elbows like I know man like
I know how to look like it people like a
pine Knoll like it if I'm a big fan of
the church it was happening and the
Perez stories I go there bro and I buy
me a ticket for our three shows or just
start and I just are like there's some
people that all do it those people know
how to do it like that one little fan
that showed up to your show on the same
night and on a Tuesday we represent went
to go see you in Riverside got in his
car and drove to the Comedy Store and
saw me at 10:30 and handed me a blunt -
there's some good people out there
there are good people that have people
church family strong they come out they
support I give them my love all the time
they're strong people so what are you
gonna [ __ ] do next time Johnny we're
gonna have dinner okay whatever you want
to eat that vegan vegan top tamales bro
walk in the tight places I'm walking to
a vegan place with people samples on you
like Italian shoes no I love Chinese
food when I came to this country that's
all there was was Chinese food I know
man I never forget down then it was
Japanese food and so now I don't need
Korean or Thai food I just stick with
the Chinese and Japanese I remember like
when we take a locals with Mike Robles
it was an angel Salazar you and I and a
bunch of New York comics we're all
eating and you order that stuff I've
never seen that fool but you know how to
order right if we're already fast I was
already like a rookie bro basic stuff
orange chicken you know how do we do it
I said give me some barbecue or
something I read barbecue and he was a
fried rice and always chicken therefore
though they're giving you give me one of
the book he order like this burrito bro
ma shumou Shu nice and crispy and I'll
put the sauce I've never heard of that
era who Mushu pork nice young on the
side Chinese anywhere on these coasts
it's the Chinese
freely got good Chinese delivered right
to the hotel you don't even have to
leave the hotel
you said you stood still across the
street from the Manhattan in New Jersey
and you said it's a Cuban restaurant
yep I stay in Edgewater okay and I could
deliver from the Cuban restaurant and I
could go up the hill and hit Rudy's
right off Gords road I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] but when I go with the
family next time we'll go with the
family I'm not staying in Jersey
there's nothing to send me I'm the fairy
the ferry ride is good
the baby thinks she's Christopher
Columbus the ferry I'm looking for
bodies I got it up on the deck I say
what are you doing out there it's cold I
want to show her body cuz everybody
jumps off the bridge every three days
there's always anytime you see you on
all that one doesn't it start with a
body and that's it there's always a body
that's yeah I'm just gonna stay in the
city but I still make that when I play
Gotham I stay in Edgewater cuz I get to
see my friends and my family and I'm
right there it's a ferry ride away it's
$13 away I get off the ferry they got a
bus to taste with the Gotham or I take
an uber you know me don't know drum I
make it nice and simple what's so fool
podcast
yeah these coming up I got what I got
Vegas Trek I got Valentine's Day in San
Jose then the following week I'm a
Treasure Island on Friday and the Fox
Theatre in Tucson on Saturday that's it
for the month nice and easy no drama
nobody gets their feelings hurt I'm
gonna be a talk Caroline's in New York
City
June 20th to the 22nd yeah I'm bringing
Lisa a bridge
well three notorious save your miles now
what so for my bring Isaac Hayes to roll
maybe bring the dog you know
squishy does New York sorry about your
cab bro I know get that full forever how
two of them the brothers brothers left
their hurts more when a cat dies than
when people die you know the saying
people die you like [ __ ] them
that's daddy like what the [ __ ]
I see his ghost and [ __ ] there's one cat
for down there when he died if it still
[ __ ] me up does he like pudding
he like he like jello or pudding
hey the cat's so at night when I would
like even tilt so nice and nice I'm
saying I would I go for one Oh jello two
point puddings I'm gonna put it and I
would like [ __ ] look to see what he
was I'd see him on the couch [ __ ]
pass that refrigerator refrigerator take
the pudding huh as I took the little off
I took it off nice and easy so he
wouldn't hear it and by the time I was
shaking the whipped cream he'd be right
behind me going wow he [ __ ] could
smell that [ __ ] dawg so even right now
today like this days I'm like I want to
chew up bunny and I'll go get a pudding
and I'll turn around to see if he's down
I'm like [ __ ] he's been dead for a year
and a half you didn't that for like two
years but these other cats just died
recently and it was sad it was a sad
house and we listened unto the baby she
just said [ __ ] word for a whole week
and a half and on her birthday party she
asked one of the kids do you want to see
my dad Harry oh she came find Harry
Harry went for a ride I'll be back
so and she hasn't asked again so thank
[ __ ] god
he killed the cat I was there not ready
for it she knows Demi's gonna do me he
was her cat solemn things were so
foolish are too cheesy Rivera color my
footstep Michael obiano Erina borrow
another knocker NGO destiny 727 Sammy I
mean I like one Michael Urbano Bailey
Chris key Danny Joseph worth some food
give us some totally haze of my what it
do out there Ali Sami Ali are going in
the struggle thank you very much
jugo tourism I'm glad you made it fine
likewise hell yeah man I'm so glad man I
wouldn't suck dick to be out there for
Tuesday Oh prepare to bro I left a
little joint it's a we just in case we
had roll up fatter was who you smoke
right before we took off yeah I always
bring extra weed
just in case you get stuck I bring a
nice vape apart panda hiding them I
sleep at your machines at the airport
here at the airport yeah I don't hit the
vapor pen when I'm home and also when I
do hit it on the road every four weeks
it hits me in the morning when I wake up
I don't have to go right downstairs at
the vapor pen and then I go down eat
breakfast then come up and wash my [ __ ]
and [ __ ] that's right but the vapor
police gives you a little buffer for a
half hour five minutes get the appetite
going then I roll the joint that I go
downstairs a breakfast I roll that
number then I go back
and take a little map you know I'm a
buffer wake up lift some weights through
some elliptical and go through the two
shadows or whatever the [ __ ] yeah it's
nice and easy nice and [ __ ] easy I
don't step out of the routine I don't
wanna go no I don't want to see no
monuments I don't see won't be news I
don't want where's your restaurant oh
it's it 20 minutes away next time what I
thought I can't walk through it I ain't
goin through it sometimes I gonna
kickboxing class if I know the people I
place where I go and kick the bag I got
like little homes beside that I'm good
to go I do it nice and easy if I could
eliminate like hopefully make sure I can
eliminate the road to once a month two
times a month is good enough for me
right now that's why I'm good I'm happy
I I want to be there I can write like I
think pictures of people those two three
weeks in a row I got too much on my
plate I'm saying yeah it's tough when
you're on the road every weekend and
then you really you literally have one
day maybe two to do like meetings
podcasts all that stuff and then those
days are just acting class and you have
to ask yourself how much do you need and
what is the deflecting meetings all the
time like the law of diminishing returns
at what point this doesn't make you more
money and it just does this for you yeah
we've seen comics come and go we've seen
comics die and we've seen the effects of
the road I've seen it I've seen it you
know it's like what's-his-name said you
know William Churchill whatever he said
that you know going from from thing to
thing his success successes from going
from Avenue Avenue with complete
enthusiasm these guys that go out every
week you can't be enthusiastic yeah
at one point you lose the enthusiasm so
I know I got the podcast I know I got
the road and I know I get asked from
time to time I gotta get an audition
ready about playing Cuban guy a bad
[ __ ] like this might kick people I
used to fight I break a chair over his
head but I like that
I don't think agents for they have a
plan for you you unless you open up your
mouth to have one plan or you putting
you on the road for weeks a month and
they think that success that's not
success that's you being lazy so it's
just I don't do what I do it so between
the podcast the comedy and my family I'm
going from area to area with success I'm
happy at home I'm happy on the road and
I'm you know you just see what works I'm
no genius I just see what works I just
see other people and what they're doing
and I see where it's taking them and you
go I don't need to do that chance to
raise my kid
you know we've all seen comic kids at
the at the different clubs and what they
look like they look lost because they
don't know the Baron so you know we live
in a society now just cuz I live in
Studio City doesn't mean I'm one of
those people I can't die how many times
I take my daughters from class and the
chick is wider than Y and I see a widow
Danny where's your parents your parents
can't even take you to [ __ ] swim class
what are the chances of that kid [ __ ]
joining the Marines and you wonder why
there's the problems we have so [ __ ]
I'd rather be a dad I go on the road and
I do the podcast and I bounce all
through mine you do the best when I was
born on the road every week in 2015 my
podcast numbers or horrible when I took
control I started hitting over a million
downloads so my agent wasn't right they
weren't right and the podcast gets the
word out this is it's our word out
this is all we got 40 years ago you need
to be on TV no more no more
I need more you know we have a podcast
we could tell people what we really want
we really feel so [ __ ] [ __ ] Philippe
[ __ ] over here
Robin over here come in the other was so
full you know they got [ __ ] a lot of
[ __ ] parking meter down in [ __ ]
Florida Open Sesame
yeah well some of that fool for narco
who look exactly like George Perez Oh
Rafa how exactly were some food thank
you very much to join Coco deal for
being a wonderful guest
I got a true friend forever and ever
since day one man thank you very much
man we love you I love you man always
Lisa thank you very much for making the
play take it possible do a tourist thing
for being the wheelman I love you guys
stay black